also I only lent a lesson which
had been moved to fall now so
badly that it had prevented me several
times and would still prevent me from seeing my
uncle a player other than that which
was reserved for the visits that the goal made him
benefit  of what my parents
with young people and of happiness I went out
and the drop to look at them the
poster column why they let me go
alone
I ran up to him I noticed in
front of his tent a car with tulle and
so many things that  had at the collieries
a red eye like with the bell tower in his
buttonhole all the scans and I heard
will arrive and a woman's voice was that
justin is a silence then the noise had to
carry confirmed the valet will
open and I was seen  seemed
embarrassed told me that my uncle was
very busy probably wouldn't be able
to receive me and antix he was going
to warn us the same way that I had
heard said also let them come in
just for fun stopping on  the
photographic photo and on your desk
where he looks so much like his mother Tenniel
to photograph her this side of
hers isn't it I would like to see him
just for a moment this body I heard
my grumbling uncle finally getting angry
two valets  room made me drag
on the table there was the same plate
of mass and not as usual my uncle
had his everyday jacket but
in front of him in a red silk dress
with a large pearl necklace the blow
sat a young woman who was
finishing eating a tangerine
the uncertainty where I was whether
to tell her madam or miss beware
blushing and are not going to turn their eyes too much
towards her for fear of having to speak to her
I  I kissed
my uncle she looks at me and smiling
my uncle told her my 900 takes my
name from me nor tell me his probably
because since the difficulties he
had with my grandfather touch it as much
as possible and  avoid
any hyphen between his f  family and this kind of
very hard relationship seems to her mother
adductors but you have never seen my
niece except in a photograph said
my uncle quickly in a gruff tone precisely
sorry my dear friend I do not meet on
the stairs the year  last when
you were so ill it is true that
I only saw for a flash of time and
that your very dark staircase but that was
enough for me to admire this damn young
man in these beautiful eyes and where  Sunnis
she enters at his with her finger a
line on the bottom of her forehead does
your niece maintain for you so puts
the same name as you proxies to
my english he mostly looks like her
father come back to my uncle who doesn't  suck each other
no more to make presentations from a
distance in 10 years the name of mom than
to do it up close it's quite his
father is also my poor mother I
know him a supper said the lady in pink
to some  ivf slight head tilt
and i never knew your poor
mother my friend you  remember
it was shortly after your great sorrow that
we met
I felt a little disappointed in this
luck, lady did not differ from other
pretty shapes
I had seen sometimes in my family, in
particular the daughter of one of our
elderly costs  of cages went every year on
January 1st but you only had the
1000 dumont the nail had the same
lively and good look she had there also frank and
and my game do not find him anything of
the theatrical aspect that I admired in
the  photographs of actresses nor
the extraction of diabolical
if a politician who would have been related
to the life that was to lead
I had difficulty in believing that it was a
cocotte and above all I would not have believed
that it was a chic coquette
if I hadn't seen the two-
horse carriage the pink dress of pearl necklaces
if I hadn't known that my uncle
knew only the highest class
but I wondered how the
millionaire who gave him his  car
and its hotel and its jewels  ux you can
have fun eating his fortune
for a person who looked quite
sandy and when it must and yet
thinking about what his life must have been
immorality troubled me almost more
than if he inherited materialize before
me in a special appearance perhaps
so invisible as the secret of
some circles these few scandals
that had brought out from his
bourgeois parents is doomed to
everyone who had been questioned and
eos and until the world and  to
notoriety is that these games of
vision 2000 her intonations of voice
seem to so many others that I
already knew made me unwilling month
considered as a young girl from a good
family who was no longer from any
family we had passed  in the
study eyes and my uncle taner a
little more geneva
my presence offer him cigarettes
tells us you know that i am used
to the one that the tale of the convoy i
told you is he jealous and she
pulled d  years the study of cigarettes
covered with foreign inscriptions
and timetables but if the left at your place
we met the father of this
young man at your place but what your nephew
balls I could forget him
he was so carried my ex who  for
me you want from year to modest is
sensitive but thinking of what I
could have been the harsh welcome which said to have
found exquisite from my father
I who knew his reserve and his
coldness I was young when by an
indelicacy  that he would have committed from
this university between the
excessive recognition granted to him and
his insufficient friendliness,
it seemed to me later that this was one
of the layers and a touching side of the role
of these chosen but studious women
who devote their generosity
the talent we stop available of sentimental beauty
because as and artists it does
not realize it does not make it enter the
frameworks of the common existence is an art
which costs them little to enrich the output
crimp  e precious and finally the
rough and rough-hewn life of men like
these in the smoking room my uncle was
in a jacket to receive it
answer his body that's where his pink silk dress comes from
these pearls the elegance that
emanates from  friendship of a grand duke just as
they had taken some
insignificant remarks from my father she had
worked with delicacy had
given him a turn a precious appellation
and hunting there one of those looks as
beautiful in shades and a
billion units  and of gratitude and laurent
of exchanged in a jewel
artist in something quite
excluded so let's see them there you
go put my uncle I got up
I had an irresistible urge to kiss
the hand of the lady in  rose but
seemed to me like this site was
something daring like a kidnapping
so aside from your while i was thinking
i know it's wondering what
to do to be able to
do something and a blinded move and
fool stripped of  all the reasons
that i found there was a moment in
his favor
i raised to my lips the hand that he held out to
me and how nice he is
said joe kals have put the small size
for women there holds his double at the
he will be a perfect gentleman
she adds, squeezing the times to
give the sentence to nelson slightly
british could he not provide
once to take a course at the small as
our neighbors the english said gold he
n  would only have to send me a stream in the morning
I didn't know what it was like
bühler
I didn't understand half of the
words that the other was saying but the fear
that we were hidden some questions to
which had  was impolite you did not
answer my seal to stop
listening to them carefully and I
felt very tired but no it's
impossible single heart we
are shoulders he is restrained he works a
lot he has all the ready to his
courage and does he whisper so that
I don't hear this lie and I
'm contradicting myself spa who may turn out to be
a little victor hugo a kind of
worth the apl you know I love using them
replied the lady in pink it's only them
who  understand women only
elite beings like you excuse me my
ignorance friends who you the beautiful
s they want a commodity that has in the
little library of the trait of your
beautiful for you
you know that you promised me
to lend it to me  to people would not take great care
my uncle who hated to lend his
books did not answer and
led me to the antechamber distraught
with love that the lady in pink
I covered with pleasure or the cheeks
full of tobacco of my old uncle  and
while with that it's a shame he
let me hear his 2nd nadia
openly that he would like as much as I
didn't spa this visit to my
parents I told him with tears in his
eyes that the memory of his kindness was
at the  less as strong as I
will one day find the mo  yen to testify
my gratitude to him
he was so strong in fact that two
hours later after a few
mysterious sentences and which did not seem to me to
give my parents unity signed the
new importance with which I was endowed I
could more explicitly recount them in
the smallest details the visit I
had just made I didn't think I was talking
to my uncle like
this I thought I did
n't want it and I couldn't imagine
that my parents were all true dumas in  a
visit where I will not enter
does it not happen every day that to
the soul he asks not to miss
the apology to a woman who he has been
tainted to write and that we  neglect
to do so judging that this person
cannot attach importance to
silence which has none for us I
imagined like everyone else that the
brain of beings was acceptable
inert and docile its specific power of reaction
on this  that were introduced there
and I had no doubt  s not as depositing from
that of my parents the news of the
knowledge that my fingernail had made me
do I did not transmit it without them
at the same time as I wished the
judgment although having that I carried
on this  presentation
my parents
unfortunately without returning to
principles entirely different from
what I managed it and to adopt when they
wanted appreciated the action of my uncle
my father and my grandfather urt with him
violent explanations
I was there  indirectly informed a few
days after cruiser to my uncle who was
passing by in a discovery car
I feel you the doula the recognition
their lies that I would have liked to
express to him next to their immensity I
find and what a tip of the hat would be
petty and could well arise in  my
uncle that I did not think I was all
bound towards him has more karim banal
politeness I resolved to refrain from this
insufficient gesture lgt turn my head
my uncle for that I was following the orders in this
are from my parents they will not
forgive them and he died many
years later without any of
us ever telling you